un style épuré et moderne avec des
touches locale voilà un aperçu d'une des
chambres standard qui sera proposée
d'ici la fin de l'année
le projet est ambitieux il concerne
quelque 196 chambres dans sa première
phase il est coûteux environ 35 millions
d'euros
projet qui veut surfer sur un nouveau
concept le bnb
business & bien-être tout ce qui est
prévu avec cette enveloppe ce n'est pas
que l'hôtel mais l'intégralité du du
complexe de l'hôtel batelière
j'entends par là non seulement donc
l'hôtel mais aussi les parkings l'accès
nous avons prévu aussi la construction
d'un certain nombre de villas hôtelières
en complément de l'hôtel qui pouvons qui
pourront venir compléter l'offre ainsi
qu'un centre de bien-être
un spa à tenant directement à l'hôtel
nouveau projet de rénovation ce n'est
pas le premier mais est-ce que celui-là
a toutes les chances d'aboutir
écoutez en tout cas nous mettons toutes
les chances de notre côté pour qu'ils
aboutissent une profonde transformation
il en est question depuis des années
sans succès voici à quoi devrait
ressembler les 124 chambres de l'hôtel
batelière dans un avenir prochain dans
un contexte de crise avec des dettes de
plusieurs millions d'euros un hôtel
fortement dégradé aucune rénovation n'a
pu être possible depuis 25 ans
la grosse différence par rapport au
projet passé c'est que non seulement
nous sommes à la fin de notre plan de
continuation
suite à nos difficultés d'il ya
maintenant presque dix ans il y a neuf
ans pour être exact donc nous sommes à
la fin de notre plan et au delà de ça
nous envoie un partenaire très solide
qui nous accompagnent qui est la caisse
des dépôts et consignations qui nous
permettra de de pouvoir apporter une
assise pour pouvoir générer tous les
financements nécessaires à cette
rénovation
la clientèle d'affaires ou de tourisme
pourra donc profiter des services d'un
hôtel 4 étoiles supérieur sur une
surface totale de 5 hectares la première
phase des travaux est prévue à partir de
juillet pour une période de 18 à 24 mois